hey guys Ryan right here so we've waited
forever for an Avengers age of Ultron
trailer and we already got another sneak
peak trailer at Avengers age of Ultron
let's watch this [ __ ] thing
[Music]
are you on my team
oh that's not a question I need answered
the handles in person whose soever is
carrying Thor's fingerprints as I think
the literal translation yes that's a
very interesting theory by the simpler
one
[Music]
how could you be worthy you're all
puppets tangled in strings haha but
[Music]
[Music]
god damn you
[Music]
it's the end the end of the path I
started us on nothing lasts forever
[Music]
probably
[Music]
[Music]
god damn [ __ ] that movie looks [ __ ]
awesome dude okay I'm not gonna lie the
first trailer I saw I was like it looks
cool it looks I'm excited but I wasn't
like pumped the way this trailer pumped
me up man that it's like the Avengers
are back the other one didn't do that
for me for some reason this one I'm like
holy [ __ ] they're back you know just
seeing them in that opening scene where
they're you know just having a fun time
like that's what I was worried this
movie will be missing when I saw the
first trailer I was like what if this is
just too serious I mean yeah it's gonna
go down some really dark paths and be
really serious but [ __ ] man having the
characters there the humor I was not
aware Don Cheadle will be in this one
that is even cooler so yeah man to
[ __ ] just see like the life in this
cuz it looks like there's a lot of life
in this movie you know like it does have
the humor still it has the personality
as the characters but it's gonna go down
much even scarier paths and the action
looks funny this looks like an epic
[ __ ] movie and I honestly believe it
is very much capable of topping the
first one and that's that's a bold
statement
that's a bold italicize that underlining
times new roman' alright guys well thank
you so much for telling me that trailer
was out if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects god
damn I'm so [ __ ] pumped for this
movie I am so excited it looks so good
and now a lot of people have been
requesting shoutouts so to keep up with
it we've created a facebook complex the
real rejects shoutouts page in order to
get a shout out just see something cool
or interesting I don't care what it is
and then yeah Daniel Sottero Ryan
big fan of your videos man I got the
same Scarface poster in my room if you
ever need to talk necks again for a
video let me know lol hooked me up with
a shout-out porfavor you [ __ ] rock
and tell Alyssa be crazy I love her
I will tell Alyssa be crazy that you
love her I'll say damn loves you and no
computer so leave its that cyber channel
down telling her that dude it's cool
that we got the same Scarface poster I
honestly like the poster more than I
like the movie not gonna lie it's one of
those movies that I don't really care
much for seen at about 12 times and for
some reason I'm just not like everybody
else know me and everybody else I mean
every gangster that watches the movie
dude nobody you on the channel if you
can come to LA and come on this channel
you're welcome Alexander Pearson can I
possibly get a shout out you guys have
been watching your videos for ages well
ages being two years then yeah good job
man
almost the two-year mark Wow Alexander
Pierson yes man Pierson that's what I
call the r.i.p is because it Pierce's a
woman's vagina you know what I mean that
sounds painful
this one's a special two-part shout out
I want to give a special shout-out to
Yusef Ashraf and jiggly jelly you guys
are always commenting you're [ __ ]
awesome I hope you two meet one day and
mate and have a child that will allow
you guys to create the ultimate YouTube
channel we'll call it Yusef jelly you're
gonna take on jiggly jellies last name
Yusef sorry I decided you're the woman
in the relationship